today I want to tell you three things
something that makes me sad something
that makes me mad
and something that gives me hope I spent
some time living in Rwanda with this
family
this is Tati her husband Pasi seek her
oldest daughter Pascaline and their
littlest baby they have five kids all
together and I want to tell you a little
bit about their lives so every day the
morning starts when their oldest son
Camille joins the procession of hundreds
of kids heading to the nearby lake to
bring water home for their family now
the water that Camille brings back is
dirty and it carries the risk of disease
but it's all they have so they cook it
cook with it and they drink it and they
hope for the best and Tati she spends a
huge part of her day in this little
metal Shack you can see behind her
cooking for her family now I would walk
into that Shack and the smoke would be
so thick that it would burn my eyes
within moments but Tati would spend
hours crouched over this open fire just
breathing in the smoke while she cooked
and a lot of the time that adorable baby
was strapped to her back breathing the
smoke right along with her and at 6:30
every day the lights would go out on
their life and anything that Tati hadn't
finished yet whether it was for her
family or her dress business had to be
done by candlelight when I stayed with
them I went to bed every night feeling
completely in awe of this incredible
woman who works harder every single day
than I ever had to work in my entire
life and every night when I would wake
up
and I would hear Tati in the next room
just coughing constantly because of the
decades of smoke that she had been
inhaling to feed her family that made me
want to cry and the thing is there are
products and services out there that can
make tattoos life so much better take
the three needs that I identified in her
life clean water water health
international gets affordable drinking
water to over five million people in
developing countries clean cooking or
Joe cook stove emit no smoke and they're
sold to twenty five thousand today
electricity huffs power gets affordable
electricity to over four hundred
thousand people who live off the grid
and these aren't charities these are
businesses they're selling these
products in communities just like
Tottie's at affordable prices and
they're doing it with profitable
business models but these businesses
aren't coming to Rwanda any time soon
and I don't know if they will in tatoos
lifetime and this makes me really sad
and now I want to tell you what makes me
mad and to do that I'm gonna take you to
Kigali Rwanda is capital he oli is full
of talented passionate people and they
want to be part of Rwanda success story
and I worked in East Africa in
government and impact investing so I've
met a lot of entrepreneurs and they
always sit down and they tell me about
how they want to change the world and I
always ask them three questions
what's your product what's your business
model and how can you prove to me that
it works but these entrepreneurs they've
never been to India they've never seen
Hoss power in action so their answers
were always less compelling and less
developed than existing businesses I
knew about that we're out there solving
best thing
problems in other countries but instead
of bringing these businesses to these
entrepreneurs and helping them figure
out how to adapt them and scale them in
their own communities we were standing
by and we were cheering them on while
they tried to reinvent the wheel and
this made me mad but what gives me hope
is I know we can change this and
changing it starts with breaking down
the problem first what's not a problem
capital the impact investing market is
eight billion dollars and these are just
some of the organizations that invest in
companies like the ones I talked about
and impact investors you can believe
they want to see the social innovation
space scale up just as much as I do so
there are a lot of great conversations
happening right now about what kind of
capital is needed in what stages and in
which sectors to really get the social
enterprise movement to scale up but I
believe that all the capital in the
world isn't gonna fix this problem if we
rely entirely on entrepreneurs to take
their businesses to new countries and
that's because of three reasons first
focus imagine that you're an
entrepreneur in India you've hit the
Holy Grail you've built a business
that's serving a need in your community
and it's doing it profitably what are
you focused on first probably reaching
as many people in your community as you
can and after that probably reaching as
many people in India as you can and that
makes perfect sense it's probably what
you should focus on but it might take 20
or 30 years and meanwhile their
communities like Tottie's whose lives
could be changed by your business but
they're not a second
perspective imagine that you are ready
to scale internationally if you've never
been to Rwanda or Cambodia how would you
know where to start and how would you
find that passionate entrepreneur in
Kigali Orpah Phnom Penh who wants to
solve a same problem and has what it
takes to bring your business to their
country and scale it up third expertise
imagine that you get yourself to Rwanda
you find the perfect market and the
perfect partner you are now entering
completely uncharted territory as a
manager managing a multinational
business is a totally different thing
from managing something small in your
community and you may have no idea how
to take this leap or where to find the
talent that can help you do that so
these three barriers are really big and
a lot of the time you have social
enterprises that reach this proof of
concept phase and they have the
potential to scale geographically and
reach a lot of lives
but they get stuck and when they get
stuck there are a lot of organizations
that are there ready to mentor them and
support them and give them money to get
it over the hump but there aren't enough
capable knowledgeable hands to
physically do the hard work of taking
these businesses to new countries so a
lot of them don't scale for 20 or 30
years and a lot of them never do this
red bar represents millions of
communities just like toddies whose
lives could be changed by existing
businesses but they're not and that red
bar is what I want to do something about
and I want to do something about it by
building a replicator an organization
that focuses entirely on taking
successful business models to new
markets in developing countries a
replicator would first determine which
of these social enterprises has the
greatest potential to scale in new
markets
and each of these dots represents a real
social enterprise that's been successful
in one country but hasn't scaled further
so we would identify replication targets
and then we would physically do the work
of taking them to new markets say East
Africa where Tati lives we would adapt
the business model and we would find
talented managers who can manage those
businesses long term and once we've done
that there would be a blueprint or a
business in a box that would allow those
businesses to keep on growing maybe
across the continent and maybe beyond I
want to make this happen for Tati for
the four billion people like her who
live on less than $4 a day and for the
entrepreneurs who want to change the
world and shouldn't spend their lives
reinventing the wheel if this is
compelling to you I invite you to join
me thank you